[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well so I'm Liz thanks for coming to my
talk first a little bit more about me so
currently I'm at statistics I'm on their
infrastructure team and I'm working on
our log pipelines and before that I was
at startup called la Glee and I also
worked on log pipelines back then and
before that I was then I was on the
newsfeed team at LinkedIn cool so how
many here have heard of stitch fix how
many here know how stitch fix works ok
so I want to start with that because I'm
going to use a few stitch fixed examples
later on I like to call stitch fix the
Pandora for clothing
so basically customers fill out a style
profile where they indicate their
stylistic preferences and then we send
them a box full of clothes and they
don't have direct input on what they get
in their box we just kind of decide what
they get and then customers keep what
they want and they send back what they
don't want
so that's stitch fix in a nutshell ok
back to this slide so you guys have all
been staring at this slide for like the
last 10 minutes and hopefully you're
asking yourselves a few questions like
what does Big Data mean in this context
is it am I just throwing that around
like a buzz word what is this log thing
and what does it have to do with big
data the question you're all hopefully
wondering is why are logs the unsung
hero big data that's maybe a bit of a
bold statement and if that's true then
how do I get me some logs I would get me
some pods ah questions so hopefully by
the end of this talk in 35 minutes
I'll have answered all these questions
for you starting with the easy one what
is Big Data mean in this context
so I'm not just throwing it around like
a buzzword I actually I'm talking about
something specific and I want to get
that out of the way right now so I'm not
just talking about scale if you have a
petabyte of data in your data warehouse
you're not a big data company you're a
big data company if you are performing
analytics on this large data set so
you're actually trying to crunch through
all this data and get value from it okay
so pretty straightforward you guys would
probably probably know that next what is
this log thing so I want to start by
answering this question in essence what
a log is and then I'm going to go into a
lot more detail later on but first I
want everyone to think for a second what
do you think a log is you hear the word
log thrown around a lot and logs have
been around for a really long time like
decades so what do you think it is okay
I don't mean log files this is not these
are not the unsung hero of big data
these are important but they're mostly
just cumbersome and annoying I also
don't mean a literal log in case that's
what you're thinking okay so for
dramatic effect I added a five-second
fade in which I love
this is what a log is
'we don't hear you one more death a log
is a data model that's all it is okay so
what kind of data model is it a log logs
are an immutable append-only data set
where each record is an event what is an
event an event represents some kind of
an occurrence hopefully pretty
straightforward an event usually follows
the format X did y at time t and i have
a footnote because maybe you're
wondering why isn't it just why happened
at time t and the answer is that X when
you have an X in here it's really useful
for partitioning and joining I won't go
into too much detail about that
but suffice it to say that normally logs
have an X did wise format so this is
kind of what it would look like you've
got time time 1 X did Y time 2 X 2 Z
then food did bar then visited visited
bar then visited bargain just a just a
series of things that happened ok so
that is in essence what a log is I'm
going to go into a lot more detail later
on when I'm explaining why logs are
great but I'm going to move on to the
next half of this question what do logs
have to do with big data so remember
that big data was about performing
analytics on large data sets and you
need accurate and well-organized data to
perform accurate and valuable analytics
we all know the same garbage in garbage
out if your data is garbage your
analytics are going to be garbage how do
you get high-quality data for your
analytics
and the next point this is important for
this talk analytics usually means
analyzing the past so not always but
usually you're looking at what has
happened in order to predict what will
happen so what kind of data represents
the past logs logs so that's what logs
have to do with big data ok so I
answered the easy questions the what
questions I'm going to focus the rest of
the talk on these harder questions the
why question why are logs so great so I
want to illustrate by counter pointing
log data with another kind of data model
that you're probably more familiar with
which is transaction data now
transaction data also known as state
data also known as operational data
actually had a debate with my colleagues
a few days ago we were trying to decide
what is the correct term for this and it
we all found various Wikipedia articles
supporting our various positions so I
think the answer is the industry hasn't
really converged on a single term for
this concept but the concept is the same
so transaction data represents the state
of the world in the present moment what
is true right now OLTP databases so
online transaction processing databases
are optimized to store this kind of
state this is because they're optimized
for many small writes and reads for
concurrent access for very like random
specific queries these databases are
really good at handling this kind of
data examples my sequel long way to be
Postgres these are typically all TP
databases all TP databases answer
questions like how many funds does this
client have how much money does
person have in their bank account right
now what does this users email address
what email just do we have on file for
this person is this passenger authorized
to fly on this plane so you go to scan
your boarding pass it's going to some
old TP Davis and we're saying yes know
the data and an alt speed database is
muted as mutated as time progresses so
this is really important records are
being deleted added and updated all the
time so compare that to log data log
data is a ledger of all the things that
have happened with log data you can
answer questions like how much money
does this client usually spend that's
really important for fraud detection how
many orders did we send last year
something that stitch rates usually
wants to answer which buttons do
customers click which buttons do
customers not click that's a hard
question to answer without log data log
data is continuously accumulating is
append-only it's written in stone this
is because you cannot rewrite history
once something happens it happened
there's there's no going back from that
so you need to have log data to record
all the things that have happened ok so
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
that your company has OLTP databases you
have these databases you can't really do
a whole lot without them because they
store your customers they store your
inventory they store all kinds of useful
things so this is maybe what your
company looked like when it was starting
out you've got a web app got your DB
you've got your happy customer so now
you want to do analytics on this old to
be database graph database doesn't keep
track of what it's state used to be that
database you can't send a query saying
hey what was your state two weeks
you like all it knows is what is true
right now in the present moment so to
analyze your data you need a record of
what has happened in the past LTP
databases don't know what their state
used to be so you need to keep track
yourself you decide to take periodic
snapshots and load them into a data
warehouse this should sound pretty
familiar because this is the classic ETL
pipeline this has been around for a
while now and it's actually not bad
you've got your database you've got your
snapshots you can analyze those
snapshots you can actually get pretty
far but ETL classic is okay but has
drawbacks so I want to dig into these
drawbacks and explain why log data
solves those problems one you don't know
how the database changed between each
snapshot so using a Citrix example we
have an item DB that tracks all the
items in our physical warehouses all of
the clothing that's sitting on the racks
and we have several warehouses so we're
always tracking what's going in and
what's going out so this is a really
simplified view of what that database
might look like we've got the SKU as the
ID and we have ask you count the number
of the SKU we have in our warehouse so
when someone purchases a shirt we
decrement this number and that's how we
keep track of of how many of this shirt
we have in the warehouse
pretty simple now snapshots if you were
to snapshot the item DB you can't really
tell what changed from day to day this
is because your snapshots would look
something like this today
you know you had zero of that shirt
yesterday you had zero of that shirt
last week you had 35 if you're being
really naive you could say
well last week between last weekend
yesterday we sold 35 shirts but in
reality a really popular shirt
we might get a shipment of a thousand
they all go into the warehouse and by
the end of the day they've all been sold
so yesterday the count was zero today
the count was zero in reality that shirt
we sold thousands of that shirt and
that's a really interesting analytical
analytical data point that you would not
be able to capture with snapshots how do
you solve this problem so one option
take more snapshots just Moeller more
snapshots that kind of gets the job done
but then you're in a urinal well--very
taking snapshots like once every five
minutes and the engineer in the app devs
are like you're taking down our database
stop taking so many snapshots
another option is join the item DVD be
with other databases like the shipment
database that's an OK solution that
might that might kind of get the job
done make the item DB append-only and
pull for new records so instead of
decrementing the value you just create a
new record and kind of tombstone the
last record I think all TP databases
depending on the data set they're not
really designed for that so I don't
think that's really a great option or
you could use logs you can use logs so
with logs how do we how do we solve this
problem a log event gets emitted each
time the item database changes with logs
you can reconstruct the databases state
at any point in time this is really
powerful because you can you can ask
questions like what items did we have in
our database in our warehouses two hours
ago while items in our warehouse do we
have two hours ago 35 minutes and 27
seconds ago you know exactly what items
were in the warehouse so I have a
footnote to explain where the long event
gets submitted to
get mitad two long pipe lines and I will
talk more about long pipe lines but
suffice it to say this is where logs go
long pipe lines so with logs you've got
the same database you decrement the
value and then you also emit a log event
saying this skew decreased by one amount
at this time so you've got the X Y T
format here okay so that's one problem
with snapshots you don't know how they
change between each snapshot you don't
know how the database has mutated - you
can only analyze data as frequently as
snapshots or taken so this might seem
pretty self-explanatory if you take a
snapshot once every 24 hours you can
only analyze that data at worse 24 hours
later but I think there are some subtle
benefits to having data flow in real
time so log data flows in real time this
is great because historical analysis and
real time applications can use the same
data flash infrastructure so more and
more people are building real time
applications to do real-time analytics
on this like stream of data that's
coming in all the time
that stream of data can be archived in
your warehouse and then you can have
batch processes that run on the same
data this is really powerful because you
can kind of much easier to switch
between a batch job and a streaming job
and your data is just kind of like has a
uniform view logs can be enriched in
real time so you can have an application
that consumes all your logs adds useful
metadata and pushes it back into the log
pipeline PII is stripped before entering
the data warehouse you can have another
stage that consumes all the leg log data
and obfuscates or gets rid of all of the
PII before it even enters the data
warehouse and corrupt data can be
prevented from entering the data
warehouse
so if you you can validate that the log
data looks the way that it should at the
time that's being
produced which is nice because you don't
get all this like crust getting into
your data warehouse and like corrupt
data that's hard to deal with later on
okay so that's one reason why having
data flow in real time those are reasons
why having data flow in real time are
really great lastly and I think this is
the real kicker is that you can only
analyze data that exists in the OLTP
database when you're taking snapshots so
why why is that a bad thing
it's transaction data and log data are
separate they can evolve orthogonal so
for example a user's geolocation is
important for analytics but irrelevant
for operational applications so the web
app doesn't need to know what this uses
geolocation is so they're not going to
want to store it in their database but
they can admit it in the log events when
an application does need to make
database changes the logs can remain
unaffected so for example the app devs
decide to migrate their database from my
sequel to Postgres if as long as they're
emitting the log data analytics doesn't
have to even know that they're doing
this many entire data sets are not
useful for operational applications but
are needed for analytics so this one is
huge because there's just rows of data
that is never going to get stored in an
OLTP database just never like clip
streams sensor data
visitor logs
another great thing when you separate
your transactional data from your log
data is that log data can be endlessly
rich so log data can capture context
around these state changes so why did
something in the old TV database change
with this context so yeah what this
context is easy to answer your question
like why why did something happen for
example at stitch fix a customer can
place a shipment from both the web app
and a mobile device the old hippy
database does not know the shipment was
does not know where the shipment was
placed it it knows the shipment was
placed but it doesn't know where the the
request came from but the logs can show
you that customers are much more likely
to place orders from their mobile
devices another great thing about log
data is that the amount of data you can
push to a log pipeline is nearly
limitless this is because log pipelines
are designed to be extremely scalable
for for large amounts of Rights so you
might be thinking gosh all this log data
sounds like so much data and it's true
it is a lot of data it is common for
sets of logs to be orders of magnitude
larger than transactional data sets so
yeah you're going to have a lot of log
data ok so I feel like we covered a lot
and there is a lot more to cover but I
only have 35 minutes so hopefully I've
more or less answered some of hopefully
I've begun to convince you that logs are
actually really handy and really
valuable when you're doing analytics and
large data sets so the last question how
do I get logs how do I get these logging
sounds so cool well you need a log
processing pipeline also known as a
message bus or event bus
so I think message bosses and event
buses are subtly different things but if
you hear people talk about message bus
or event buses they probably mean a log
processing pipeline so just so you know
log pipelines transport data in real
time and maintain the order of when data
was written consumers subscribe to a
topic producers push data to a topic and
data propagates to all subscribed
consumers so this is kind of like a
table like a my sequel table a topic has
a collection of related data logically
related data such as like the click
stream from a certain web app or like
the the paths that the workers are
walking in our warehouses in districts
log processing pipelines are backed by a
message Ripper technology such as Kafka
Google pub/sub or a de BES Kinesis
streams so if you hear those words being
thrown around that's this is what
they're for and a message broker is just
a database that is optimized for
extremely high write and read throughput
I think some people are kind of like
mystified like what is this log
processing pipeline like it sounds like
such an interesting new kind of
infrastructure no it's just a database
that's optimized for certain use cases
ok so that's a log processing pipeline
and you might be thinking to yourself oh
right so back to this picture this is
what your company might look like if you
had log pipeline you've got your web app
you've got your DB that's not changing
but now you're emitting these log events
they're going through the pipeline you
might have applications that consume all
the log data rich it shut the DI and
then ingest them into your data
warehouse they might also ship it to
other applications that do streaming
analytics or
real-time alerting or whatever but in
the end you get these these logs for
each day looks pretty similar to your
database snapshots but the way the data
is being modeled is different so now you
have logs from April 19 you have logs
from April 20th so on and so forth okay
so you might be thinking to yourself oh
great
another piece of infrastructure to
maintain or to convince by data platform
team to build but log pipelines are
incredibly useful so why are they useful
because a centralized log pipeline can
be used by an entire organization or
even across an entire company very
leverageable piece of infrastructure to
a log pipeline greatly simplifies the
problem of data integration so what I
mean by that what I mean by that is how
does data get from the applications that
produce the log data to the applications
that need the log data this is not
something that many companies solve very
well okay three a robust log pipeline
enables a slew of event-driven in
real-time applications and operations so
with logs flowing in real-time you can
do so many things that you couldn't do
back in the snapshot wall back in back
with ETL classic so without a central
log pipeline your tech stack probably
looks something like this you've got all
these applications producing data on the
Left you've got all these applications
producing data on the right or consuming
it on the right and without a
centralized standard way to get data
from A to B people are going to just
start making their own solutions they're
going to create their own connectors
they're going to have their own api's
they're going to have a bunch of random
scripts and this can turn into an
operational nightmare and the quality of
your data suffers when you don't have an
organized way of transporting your data
with a log pipeline every application
needs to only only need to integrate
with the pipeline in order to produce
and consume log data from across the
whole organization so that's what it
might look like in this case every
application that's producing this data
only has to produce it to the pipeline
it is completely doesn't know who is
using the data who is consuming it it
doesn't care
all the people consuming data they don't
really know where the data comes from
they just know it's flowing through the
log pipeline and all I have to do is
hook into the log pipeline so it's
really really easy to put it another way
what if every time you wanted to get
data it felt like getting power from
here you just had to walk down to the
local power pole like with your like
wire hook it into this like mess of
wires and then string it back to your
house and like that's how you got power
about that's like I think this is what
it feels like when you don't have a lot
of pipeline or do you want getting data
to feel like that you just have an
outlet in the wall you plug your your
appliance into it and boom power and one
last thing that is so great about log
pipelines is the data is flowing in
real-time so I'll use another statics
example which is the style profile at
Citrix customers fill out these style
profiles of stylistic preferences and
our clothing recommendations are based
off of that data partly based off of
that data so there's a problem if a new
customer fills out their profile and
immediately orders a shipment in the ETL
classic world and if we were taking
snapshots daily we couldn't really do
this because we don't have we don't we
can't crunch through the the new style
profile data until the next day
but with snapshots oh
with snapshots this yeah this is what
the solution like this is what it looks
like you've got your web app you've got
your style DB you're taking your style
DB snapshots and then a day later you
process through the snapshots and then
you generate your feature eyes style
data and you can only use that like a
day later at the earliest with logs the
solution might look something more like
this so the customer fills out their
style profile and a profile updated
event gets submitted into the log
pipeline and we have another app that
consumes these events and can calculate
the features for that customer in real
time so now as soon as they've updated
their profile we're ready to recommend
clothing for them this is really nice
because not only is it faster it's also
a lot more scalable you don't have to
worry about taking snapshots of the
entire database every day once you start
to have a lot of customers it starts to
become pretty cumbersome so that's yet
another reason why log pipelines are
really useful so yeah that's that's
pretty much why I think logs are the
unsung hero of Big Data and hopefully
I've begun to convince you of that as
well
to recap Big Data we basically mean
analytics analytics needs accurate and
high quality data also analytics usually
means analyzing the past what kind of
data models the past bugs yeah what is a
log a data model log data is an
immutable append-only data set where
each record is an event log data is
different and often more useful than
transactional data maybe that's a bit of
a bold claim but I do believe that
distinguishing between your logs and
your transactional data allows each data
set to evolve or fog
and unchanged your analytical
capabilities from the constraints of the
LTP databases and log data is collected
by log processing pipeline and log
processing pipelines
are really useful for a lot of things so
don't so find me during office hours
thanks thank you find me during office
hours and get really pull stitch fix
socks we have these like argyle socks
they're really really nice so I'll just
be handing them out at office hours
tweet me at Susie Bennett or email me
Elizabeth up Bennett at Citrix comm and
also the obligatory we're hiring like
crazy so talk to me if you want to work
for Citrix and questions all right Thank
You Liz we have time for some questions
okay miss Chris luck my name is
Christopher I'm Western Union so one of
the interesting things you said was that
history cannot be undone yeah and in our
case I'm in the fraud division you know
we have a lot of people who accounts get
hacked and so forth so for example just
like somebody gets arrested and
convicted for a crime they didn't commit
they have a huge history of things that
really shouldn't be attributed to them
and that can later on consequences in
how you treat that yeah account let's
say yeah how do you deal with data like
that which in Everly yes did happen but
it really should not be considered hmm
so you actually do want to go back and
rewrite history because you wrote
history wrong in the first place yeah so
there that's a pretty difficult problem
this is why it's nice to archive all the
data because you can run these batch
jobs like that can go in and like fix
stuff when stuff breaks like stuff will
break in that case I would almost say
it's kind of it would almost be useful
to have a record of the fact that you
guys screwed it up in the first place
like so you might just want to copy the
data and have like okay that's
like this is the old log data back when
we were wrong she has a new log data
that it has been corrected but I don't
think that the old log data should
really necessarily be like like blown
away and just like gone forever because
you never know what you're going to want
to need a year later you might want to
go back and say hey remember that time
we screwed up that customers data like
what have we actually screw up about it
and you might want to go back and like
look at it did actually happen
somebody did single account it uses for
fraudulent purposes mmm okay yeah okay
and that tastes like you want it ah okay
I think in that world I would I would
see the log data did happen that
customer did did do those transactions
possibly in your in your materialized
view of what is true what is truth like
the olofi databases you know that like
this customer didn't commit those
actions but they did actually happen
with this account like you kind of I
think it's useful to just like still
yeah I don't know it's like pretty use
case dependent then there's that whole
history oh yeah
whoo yeah I'd like no matter what you
should keep the original data because
that did happen like that was what
happened and then you might want to have
a different materialized view of the
like the cleaned data that you know is
actually their transactions and does
that not argue for just a separation
between the data flows and the
application logic and then if you think
of like the model as a piece of
application logic right because you're
using it to make decisions like you can
you can decide like what what pieces of
the log are not valid for that
application sure but as I said I think
maybe because the bigger problem is the
propagation effect that has already
taken place in a lot of cases I mean
that's not part of the log now that's
part of some other transaction history I
mean in our case you know on some severe
let's say criminal cases we work with
the FBI so you know if we see that your
account was used to transfer money to
some drug mules you're now on the FBI's
whatever list so you know it's it gets
complicated really really quickly yeah
that's true I still think the fact
remains that that did happen and then
figuring out why it happened is
something that is sort of a separate
problem
at to this question yesterday there was
a talk about hoodie open-source library
from Hoover they have similar problem I
think that library was supporting a lot
making updates on a large data set in a
they have two different models and we
talked to those people holding open
source lyrics yeah I think in this case
it does probably help to not not remove
the log record but maybe update a column
or something to indicate that this was a
fraud record and that way every also has
provisions for triggering something for
the derived people's to be updated as
well yeah yeah yeah I think that makes
sense I think the log data is just sort
of like the raw data of what we know
happened and then the derived tables can
you can kind of join when you're doing
your analysis joint on the derive tables
indicating like this log this happened
but it didn't really happen like things
like that my name is Mark from New Relic
my question is what what in your
experience have you found is the ratio
between log data that has to be
manufactured well SP generated
especially from the application layer
versus just hooking into say in my
sequel bin log or a web server long file
like what do you see is the ratio
between those yeah that's a really good
question so it's kind of there's kind of
two main approaches to collecting log
data you've got the change data capture
where you actually hook into the
database itself and you listen for the
changes that happen on on the database
and then you've got event sourcing which
is where the application produces those
events and like the application is kind
of responsible for for creating that
stream of log data I think the change
data capture makes sense if you have
let's say a database and you have a
cache and whenever the database changes
you will need to update whatever is in
the cache like they're pretty closely
coupled like what they change data
capture you still
are pretty limited to what the database
has if you're just looking at what
Records changed what records were
created and deleted you're still really
chained to that your old tobe database
and you're chained to the semantics of
that database so I think in general it's
it's actually more freeing and more
flexible to produce events from the
applications itself because the
application logic can add a lot of
things the application logic can just
add metadata and useful like just you
know all kinds of things that wouldn't
necessarily go into the into them into
the old TP database so I think it's a
little use case dependent but for a lot
of like historical analytics and things
that just kind of you want to have a
logical view of what happened I think
it's a little bit more useful to produce
the logs from the event from the
application logic the only thing that
the only downside to that is that it's
more error-prone so what if the
application forgets to omit a log event
so that's one of those things that you
have to really be good about
establishing best practices and working
with the the people who develop the
application and like making sure that
they actually have unit test making sure
that the log event was produced like
they have integration tests and when
they're testing new code they're
actually validating the log events are
being produced still so